[Music]
okay
so this is my review of the new hulu
film
happiest season this is directed by
claya duvall
it's also written by clay duvall and
mary holland who plays
jane in the film so i have to start this
review giving a shout out to my sister
she is somebody who has incredible
foresight when i send her a trailer
she knows right away and always calls it
right if something's gonna be good or
not
and she sent me this trailer for
happiest season was like
you need to review this this is gonna be
a hit and
i was skeptical i hadn't heard about it
but i decided to give it a shot
and once again my sister has called it
correctly
i was so impressed by this film what
makes it even more impressive
is that this is only the second film
clay duval has directed
and wrote and this is the first
screenplay that mary holland has written
on
and why it is so amazing that with such
a small resume in those categories to
have
such a strong script and such a funny
script
why this script works so well is it
really
just obeys old writing rules that if you
just
hit these things your script should be
decent at least
and it nails what you need to nail in
the sense that
it only takes 11 minutes for this film
to get to the big
twist conflict reveal of what we're
gonna have as the simple basis here that
you have this lesbian couple of harper
and abby
going to harper's house for christmas
but
harper lets abby know 11 minutes into
this film that
her family doesn't know she's out and
her family obviously doesn't know about
the relationship
it's such a great concept for all the
comedy to shine here just off of that
once that's known what's so effective
about this film is it
right then puts you in the shoes of abby
you feel like you're with abby along
this whole ride
and clay duval directs this really well
too because
the camera work here until we gain
sympathy later on for harper
we're constantly supposed to gain
sympathy for abby and relate to abby
because she films abby in a lot of
close-up shots
medium shots where a lot of times when
we see harper
until the end of the film she's shot
further away we're supposed to distance
from her because as the movie goes on
they're distancing from each other and
what makes the writing about this
so effective not just in setup and how
quickly they get to the conflict here
and keep it
everything moving every scene in this
film
serves what the film is trying to say
and there's really two big things this
film's really hitting on
it's really shown in aubry plaza's line
when she says
to kristen stewart the thing i can
relate to is being in love with someone
who is afraid to show the world who they
are
that's what this movie's showing you is
this type of relationship between abby
and harper
and that abby you're sympathizing with
because
you feel for her that harper is keeping
her hidden but where it twists you is
then we get
dan levy's great monologue to avi later
on
when he's talking about how it was
easier situation for you to come out but
not everyone has that
blessing where their families totally
understanding
and it gives you that lesson with the
film about
it's not even about you your partner not
coming out right away or in a difficult
situation of judgment like this
it's about them and what they also you
have to sympathize what they're going
through so the
movie really shows you that it's
important to be who you are and brave
and come out with it but it also shows
you the effects
on both partners and how if you're the
one not in that
situation there's got to be some
understanding there of how hard that
situation that is but
on harper's end her to have to
understand how that also affects your
partner because you're trapping them and
they feel completely distanced and
closed off which just film effectively
shows and how
complicated relationships like this can
get in this situation and
with writing the best writing comes in
when you're writing these characters
lives you're in the middle of the most
chaotic situation in their life and if
you were to look at a story
of this relationship as their life goes
on this
hands down would be the most chaotic
when they first meet the family with
this big secret
and they're learning so much about each
other leading to great character growth
with harper
and abby where abby's character growth
is serving the message of the film
because
she comes around to understand harper's
situation and be sympathetic
where harper's character growth is that
she finally comes around to being
honest and being who she really is to
her family and to
not be afraid to share who she is in
love with so it checks off all the marks
there
thematically and it really works so well
now when we're talking about comedy here
what impressed me so much is to me
comedy has really struggled in film
since
early 2000s i think it's mostly been
horrible and i haven't laughed at much
stuff
but i don't remember the last time i
laughed so much
in a movie and why i applaud the writing
comedically for this film is that it
doesn't let you
go it just keeps whipping out the jokes
and they're all landing you see a
problem a lot of comedies now is they're
not whipping out enough jokes or they're
whipping a lot of jokes out
and a lot of them aren't landing and
they're just leaving it there and not
trying to make it better
this film has so much subtle humor that
goes on
even some of the jokes have multiple
layers to it you have to catch little
mannerisms when things are hinting at
it's so well done and it lets the
performances shine i think what was the
most enjoyable thing about watching a
movie like this
and is why you have to applaud clay
duval's directing is that
it's this big ensemble cast with all
these big names and you always get
worried because the history of that
with movies especially christmas ones
they usually fail it's just too many
cooks it doesn't work but
here everyone gets a moment to shine
every character gets a payoff
and you get so into one person's
performance you almost forget there's
other people that are great in it too
and then you're like pleasantly
surprised and excited like oh yeah
allison breeze here and then
oh aubry plaza is here so it like
constantly keeps you on your toes that
way and
it really is like the perfect balance to
pull off having like
a team of avengers and actors if that
makes sense to
have such an ensemble they usually fail
but this one did not
and to top off the accomplishment for
this film for me is that
my belief is that i truly believe we had
not
had a christmas hit one that will be a
classic for
future generations and that every time
you go through the christmas movies to
watch
you're gonna put one on we haven't had
one since elf which was in 2003 people
it is
20 20. that's 17 years later i will say
confidently this
is our first christmas hit since 2003
that will go
into that class of okay put it on the
christmas movie shelf this is
rewatchable it's a christmas
success and that is so rare and that
needs to be applauded too
and what does it do so well also that
will hook a lot of people into this is
it's so timely especially the humor
it's very accurate with how we are today
especially little things like the mom
with the
being obsessed with the instagram
account and using the ipad everything
felt very
in this time and i love humor too with
dan levy with the
goldfish and he flushes it down the
toilet i know when he calls her back
he's at the pet store
just so good even the slapstick humor
was gold here
in particular the scene where mary
holland has the case of
wine bottles and picks it up and they
all just spill it was just striking
comedy gold in
almost every scene and when i'm talking
about subtle things just a little quick
humor that they just add it keeps going
like when they all go out to dinner in
the beginning
first time abby's with the family and
then they bring her out this small chair
and then mackenzie dave was like you
sure it's okay she's like yeah it's just
hysterical visually
seeing her sit in that chair with
everybody and being that this movie is
about an hour 40 minutes
it times out well where you're getting
to me an hour of like
insanely funny comedy and then you get
the payoff thematically and that's where
it hits hard and everyone's gonna be
crying especially assuming harper's
coming out and it's so earned but
it gives you everything you need in a
christmas movie for it to be successful
and what people are looking for in this
type of film and what i'm talking about
it successfully gives even the side
characters growth they all
follow again simple but timely great
writing rules of
every character starts somewhere but the
end of the film they get somewhere else
there's character growth it's one pole
to another
and this comes in this final scene it
may ripe up
really fast and i think i could see the
criticism there but i think it's one of
the only
certain ways you can pull it off in the
time frame of how long the movie is
without getting maybe dragged out which
i'd rather take
not dragged out than kind of feeling a
little rush at the end with certain
characters but again because they're
minor characters so i don't feel
cheated and you get that with the
parents them coming around and how they
raise their kids and what was wrong with
it and you get that with the sisters
and you even get it really funny how
even jane
my favorite character in this film and i
thought mary holland stole the show
when she gets her line i don't have any
secrets but i'm an ally was hysterical
but the point of her always feeling
left out of everything and not taken
seriously it all hit even sloan with
allison brie who
really shows her range here she was
great i didn't even know she could play
this type of character so well
she absolutely crushes but how she comes
out in her own mini story about her
divorce so
all their fear to their family and their
parents and their parents realizing what
they've done
wrong and raising their kids and how
they went about it now my
one gripe is that i do agree with i saw
a critic say in his writing that he
thinks
aubrey plaza and kristen stewart have
way more chemistry than christian
stewart mackenzie davis when i first now
watched the film i thought oh well
that's clear
and obviously that's purposeful for the
first half but then
because she doesn't end up with aubry
plaza's character i do feel like the
moment where harper comes crawling back
for abby
and they end up together and you're like
supposed to feel like really happy
that harper got her back i was sitting
there thinking
i wish aubry plaza actually got abby
here yes it doesn't make sense with the
story what the
message is trying to say but i think
that comes with maybe
a little error of aubry plaza's
character being a little too likable
because that kind of took away from
trying to get us to really
feel that feeling of having harper get
abby back at the end there in that last
sequence and then be excited she got her
i was kind of like no i think abby
and aubry plaza's character riley were
the actually the perfect match
because their chemistry was off the
charts so if they knew their camera
shoes me off the charts
there had to be something to make her a
little less likable so that you were
actually
happy that abby ended up with harper
instead of her so that was kind of in
the back of my head
so i think that kind of deterred the big
moment there at the end but
that's a small gripe but i really love
how this all rounded out
i love how it comes full circle now that
this film started where abby wasn't even
asked to be in the family photo to take
the picture
at the end she's in the family photo so
for me i'm giving this film
a 9.5 and that my friends
is like record for christmas movie again
i can't even
imagine a christmas movie since elf
that's near that rating and again that
was in 2003.
let me know what you thought of this
film down below i'd really love to hear
your thoughts on it
and please if you love what i do here i
ask for
a small two dollar monthly donation
you'll see a paypal link in my
description
that will be able to give me the
opportunity to be able to do this
full-time and make more videos for you
guys
if you can subscribe to my channel that
helps in so many ways
and if you can follow me at steve barley
show on twitter
and instagram i will be forever grateful
and you can check out my new official
website
www.stevarly.com and like i said make
sure to share your thoughts i read every
comment
and try to respond as many as i can and
i'll see you next time